I gotta tell you you can feel the
excitement Andy is among the at least
100 million that are feeling the effects
from the worst air quality in the world
I'm here in New York on day two as the
city faces threats of smoke and haze
from the Canadian wildfires now if I'm
being honest it is a lot better here
today than it has been but people are
still walking around here on the streets
with their masks on to try and stay safe
because the smoke is expected to linger
until tomorrow
this is like the end of the world
walking around here
with all this smoke look you can't even
see Midtown back there
oh my God it's been the weirdest couple
of days in New York with this very scary
right it made it nearly impossible to
even see the buildings here in New York
City they say being outside is like
spoken three to 11 cigarettes a day on
Broadway performances were canceled Jody
one woman show prima facie
stopped the show and said she couldn't
breathe and walked off stage you
couldn't tell because I'd never seen it
if it was part of the show at first and
the curtain dropped and everybody's kind
of like what's going on
[Music]
thick they finally said she's not gonna
come on
Chris Stapleton post
state New York which was scheduled for
tonight and several major league
baseball games were called off too
there's Yankee stadium look at that
we're just dealing with this smoke
but I'm praying for everybody around
these fires and thank you to the firemen
who are doing the Lord's work
this is insane